Ohio State University thank you
thank you for the invitation uh to come
here
I feel like I'm very loud but I guess
it's okay
um right so I'll start with uh some
motivation background so this is summer
Ready's regularity Lemma which I think a
lot of us are familiar with but it says
that
for all Epsilon greater than zero
there's some bound M depending on
Epsilon so that any sufficiently large
graph
you can partition its vertex sat into at
most end parts
um so that almost so that all the parts
have roughly almost the same size and so
that almost all the pairs are what's
called Epsilon regular
that's a little bit beside the point
what exactly Epsilon regular means here
although I think I guess in this
audience
um likely most of you know what this
means but it means if you don't it just
means like roughly speaking it looks
kind of like a random graph
so yeah I get I think of this talk to
logicians so I have to like
um okay so this is a really useful
theorem and and has many applications
and something that's important to you
know the context in which this theorem
can be applied is like how how this m
depends on the Epsilon
so
um so of course one wants to know like
what is what is the form of this bound
and the proof the proof gives like a
tower type bound
and of course showed that that it must
be a tower type not so there are graphs
for which the smallest Epsilon regular
partitions have to have at least this
many parts some Tower and Epsilon
inverse
um right and of course the twx for this
talk will mean like a tower of twos of
height X
um right and then okay a more optimal
Bond bound was uh obtained by Common and
fox
so so the bound is is very large I guess
depending on your perspective
um so
uh Okay so
so I want to talk about
um
sort of so the the ideas I guess the the
band cannot be improved in general like
for General graphs so then kind of a
shift a shift in the question would be
well wonder what circumstances can you
improve about okay when when can you
obtain kind of more
robust structure results
so given a graph G I'll let like Curly F
sub G be the set system on the vertex
set consisting of the sets of
neighborhoods of points sorry this
should say B
that's the neighborhoods where V ranges
over the vertex that
okay and this n of V is just the
neighborhood of the vertex
so this is so it's a collection of
subsets of the vertex set obtained by
taking the the neighbors of every vertex
in the graph
so this is a you know a reasonable set
system and we say that the VC dimension
of G is the VC dimension of this set
system if you don't know what VC
Dimension is I'll tell you I'll tell you
what it means in this context the graph
G has VC Dimension at least k
if there are vertices A1 through a k and
maybe I'll draw
okay and for every subset okay so I have
these vertices A1 through a k
and then for every subset of the of one
through K you have another vertex
B sub s
who connects to exactly the points in s
and to none of the points outside of us
so it's essentially saying that you can
encode the power set of the of the set
of integers from one to K yeah
BS is allowed to be one of the AI right
it's any subset of one through k no like
the vertex BS can be one of the AIS that
is yes yeah yeah
okay
um
right okay so so the idea is that
um saying you have BC Dimension at least
K is saying that you're in you're at
least in at least complicated in this
way you can encode this amount of like
the power set graph okay so the higher
the idea is that if you if you put kind
of a bound on the VC Dimension that's
much smaller than the sides of the graph
sizes of the vertex set that's a way of
saying that the graph is kind of low
complexity so it's unable to encode it's
on it's unable to encode power sets of
large sex
um and I yes and I guess yes all right
okay so so this is a theorem um the
attrib these are the attributions here
so um but the in slightly different
context some some stating the theorem
and then this is the more specific
information so the theorem says that um
for any K and Epsilon there's an m so
that for all sufficiently large graphs a
VC Dimension at most k
so this is like saying load low
complexity in the sense the VC
Dimensions at most k
any graph like that has an Epsilon
regular partition where all the regular
pairs they're not just Epsilon regular
they don't just look like random graphs
they look like random graphs of density
close to zero or close to one
so this saying so saying you have
density near zero or one implies your
Epsilon regular or maybe you know
depends on what I mean by mirror but um
you know if you're within Epsilon of
zero or one you're already root Epsilon
regular so this is this is a stronger
statement than the just plain regularity
Lemma
so so for a general graph you may have
regular pairs of density like a half a
third and that's saying those pairs look
like random graphs of density a half a
third Etc and this is saying that here
if you bound this VC Dimension you can
ensure that all the densities are close
to zero or one so when you take like the
quotient structure arising from the
regular partition you have like this is
giving you even more information it
looks even more like the quotient
structure
um okay so this um
and the most okay so this is interesting
but the most interesting part is that is
what what I'm omitting here which is the
behavior of M in this theorem so Alan
Fisher Newman first proved this um in in
the bipart type case and they show that
the M can be taken as
um polynomial in one over UPS
so there's so not only do you get the
zero one density Behavior but you get
this drastic improvement in the bounce
so in the general regularity Lemma that
this was a tower of twos of height
Epsilon inverse and now this is
polynomial in epsilon inverse
and then lavasim segity gave a proof
um or proved this for for all for
General graphs
um with a a similar bound that's
polynomial and some function or it's
polynomial and Epsilon inverse with the
exponents
okay so
um I like to sort of
combine the theorems I've showed you
into a like a dichotomy type theorem
because I think it kind of
this is like this is like the most the
most interesting way to State this from
my perspective
um and that's in the setting of
hereditary graph properties
so a hereditary graph property is a
class of finite graphs oh I guess I
didn't oh that definition's not here all
right a hereditary graph property is a
class of finite graphs closed under
induced subgraphs and isomorphisms
so all of our favorite classes of graphs
are or many of them are hereditary graph
properties so things that omit you know
triangle free graphs H3 graphs
class of graph submitting an induced
subgraph etc etc okay and actually every
hereditary graph property is
characterized by saying you omit a
certain collection of induced sub graphs
all right
um
so given a hereditary graph property H
and an Epsilon I'll let M sub h of
Epsilon be the minimal integer so that
all sufficiently large all like all yeah
all sufficiently large elements in the
class have an Epsilon regular partition
with at most this many parts
so it's measuring it's measuring it's
like the the
partition size function or something
associated to the class
and so the idea is that you can you know
I'm interested in sort of results that
like separate hereditary graph
properties along structural lines and
you have to kind of look for parameters
to measure the structure and so these
theorems that I've showed you give you
give you such a such a separation so
this stack you can now State this
theorem as a dichotomy and this is a you
just amalgamate like the lower bound
gowers and the nice uh the the nice
structure theorems of Alan Fisher Newman
and Lovato yeah
I mean I think you can adapt the gowers
construction so that um once you have
um unbounded VC Dimension you can build
something like that
because if you have unbounded VC
Dimension you can construct in the
property any like bipartite
configuration you want
okay anyway I believe I mean I never I
never proved this for myself I think I
read this
possibly paperback
so so this is something that I observed
at some point okay yes okay so I should
say that this is I guess also this
observation is due to Jacob
but I do think I read it in in a paper
by you so yeah yes
but but anyway this it's become very
important to me this like this phrasing
of it so so
um so thank you I guess
um so
right so the as a corollary you have for
any hereditary graph property one of the
following hold either the VC Dimension
is finite meaning there's a uniform K so
that everything in the property has VC
Dimension at most K and in that case M
of H MH of Epsilon is polynomial and
Epsilon inverse sorry this should be an
Epsilon inverse
on the other hand if it has infinite VC
Dimension then this has to be a tower in
epsilon
so the idea here is that
um you can phrase you can phrase this as
a this is a I would call this a
dichotomy for hereditary graph
properties because on the there's a gap
here there's there's a there's a huge
gap between polynomial and Tower and so
especially in model Theory we're very
interested in in these dichotomy type
theorems where you have like really tame
behavior and then substantially more on
Untamed behavior in the other case where
there's a separation and complexity
so so to a model so I think for a model
theorists which is kind of the other
area and then this is like the nicest
way to phrase
okay so I want to talk a little bit
about extending this theorem to
hypergraphs and um so it it had already
been extended to hypergraphs in a
certain context
um so we'll Define a notion of VC
dimension for a k uniform hypergraph and
so what we do is we can we can take h a
k uniform hypergraph and then take the
the set system consisting of
um neighbors of K minus 1 points and now
this is a set system on the vertex set
and so you can ask about its VC
dimension
because okay right if you take K minus
one vertices and you take their the set
of neighbors of those people that's a
set of Singletons
um and so you can say you can decide to
call the VC Dimension the VC dimension
of this set system
and this definition is due to Fox pox
suit
um hopefully I'm stating this correctly
uh do I think it's into the exponent of
one of reps on linear and D I thought it
was the duel
because when you're in the duel
and that's why I plugged in two to the
Deep instead of the Dual to the D plus
one okay I'll have to double check okay
yeah
yeah so no I mean I could for some
reason I keep missing this uh but I I
checked this morning and it said dual
photo okay hopefully
um
so
uh the okay so this theorem is fox fox
souk and it says for any sufficiently
large K uniform hypergraph of UC
Dimension MSC you can find an aqua
partition so that almost all of the K
tuples of Parts have the property that
the the density of edges in that K2 bowl
is close to zero or close to one so I
guess like maybe we'll draw a picture in
the case where K is three what do I mean
yeah so like what is the statement
saying so it's saying you can partition
the vertices into pieces
and let's say let's say k is three so
I'm talking about three uniform
hypergraphs then it's saying for almost
all the ways to pick three pieces out of
the partition almost all the edge almost
all the triples here are edges or almost
all the triples here are not edges
so that's what the theorem is saying
so again this is a like hypergraph
analog of the the structure theorem for
graphs about a VC dimension
okay and again you get a really nice
polynomial bound here
um and the density so this density
condition so in the grass case if you
have a pair of density near zero or one
you get that it's Epsilon regular and
you get that thus it's you know it has
all these equivalent quasi random
properties
here saying that you have like a triple
which has density close to zero or one
for like a three uniform hypergraph
implies a notion of hypergraph quad
Uranus which I've seen referred to in
the literature as weak regularity but
probably has other names
so there's many Notions of Quasi
Randomness for hypographs and this
having density near zero and zero or one
in this sense like implies one of them
which I'll call wheat regularly
um
okay so in a certain sense this is like
a satisfying analog of
um of the theorem it's interesting that
actually if you go to look for a
characterization in terms of hereditary
properties of hypergraphs
the the condition is not actually this
um VC Dimension it's something slightly
deeper
so Julia and I worked that out in a in
our in a very long paper series
but that's not the topic of this talk so
it's just in this side um but there
there is a there is a theorem we do have
a theorem that's an if and only if and
it the condition is slightly weaker than
than this here
are there lower bounds like on the
dependence on DC Dimension oh on the
bounds yeah I don't know about that one
yeah so our sorry our characterization
is not in terms of the bound but rather
in terms of whether you can have a
structure theorem with the density
that's it yeah that's an interesting
question there's a lot of like there's
just a lot of questions when you go to
the hyper graph setting
um
um okay right so this is so so this is
right like I said a satisfying kind of
analog
um and I also wanted to mention that a
couple model theorists attained related
results kind of using infinitiary
methods
um but I think
because their methods are infinitary you
know they're missing some things from
here like the echo partition and the
balance
okay so
um but the work I want to talk about
today is the goal was to kind of look at
analogs of Team regularity lemmas
for like this much more complicated
notion of hypergraph regularity that was
developed um in order to obtain like a
like a general counting Lemma
um so so so this type of regularity was
developed by a lot of people here's a
list of
people who were involved with this
um Frankel gower's quiet Cowan Eagle
Rotel skoken shocked and I hope I hope I
kind of got all the main people here but
there's a lot of papers on this um
right so anyway so this notion of Quasi
Randomness is or is like yeah much more
complicated I'm gonna try and explain it
um but the rough idea is that like in
the graph setting so I guess in this
chart I'm sort of thinking of this row
is for like binary things like graphs
this row is fraternary things like
ternary hypographs this is for four
Aries
and so in the in the graph setting you
know the regularity limo has like a
structure component a quasi Randomness
component an error component
in the graph's case the structure is
like the partition of the vertex that
quas Uranus is the regularity and then
you've got the like irregular pairs when
you move to the ternary setting in this
context the structure the structure
component becomes much more complicated
because you now have a partition of the
underlying vertex set along with the
compatible partition of the pairs and
then you have a more complicated notion
of Quasi Randomness that sort of deals
with the the way the ternary edges are
distributed across the the binary
partition
so so this is just a preview and now I'm
going to
actually attempt to try and explain a
little bit about what this is uh
I've now like uh I've given this talk
several times and now there's three
slides explaining hypergraph regularity
so I think that as I've removed
information I think it's become more
understandable but we'll see so
um right so I'm going to focus on the
case where K is 3 because that's where
this result lives anyway and it's kind
of easier to visualize
um
so so first we have to start with like
what is our notion of structure what's
the what's the analog of the vertex
partition in the graph setting and so
this is going to be okay and I should
say the terminology I'm using comes from
a paper of Franco and rhodol
so so I'm following that notation
um so we'll see a TLD
decomposition for a Vertex set consists
of a partition of the underlying set
okay so you have a Vertex partition
and then for each pair in the partition
vivj you partition the set of pairs
between vivj
and so T is measuring how many
how many like vertex pieces you have and
the L is measuring how many
um pieces you have in between so I so I
usually think of the the partition in
between is like coloring the edges into
L colors
so you have t vertex
parts
and you have in between each pair of
Parts all different colors
um and the colors will denote by like
you know P if this is vivj this is like
p i j one
maybe the black one is p i J2 maybe
there's only two in this case
so this is like the this is like the the
basic unit of decomposition
all right and so what's going to replace
the notion of regular pair in this
context it's going to be something
called a regular Triad
um so a Triad is going to be
um maybe I'll have one more color
it's going to be a three-partite graph
and it's going to be obtained by taking
um three pieces from the vertex
partition so like a vi v j v k
and then in between each piece you pick
a edge color
so maybe here I pick
p i j
Alpha
and here I pick
oh this is also black p i k gamma no
beta
and then
oh no here's green
here this is like pjk
so so the this is a three-partite graph
so a Triad is just a three-partite graph
obtained in this way
and now
um I want to point out though that uh
the important part of this is that you
can kind of partition the triples
approximately in the graph
um as follows so so if I have a Triad so
G is going to denote this Triad so I try
to use G for graphs and like H for hyper
graphs so if G is this Triad then
triangle of G is the set of triangles in
the graph so it's the set of triples
where
um
okay I have a triple here and it's a set
of triples where
the
sides are like the right color
the right colors so it's a set of
triangles that are like red green black
like this
so not you know not all the vertices are
going to be making triangles here
so but on the other hand if I P if I
pick an arbitrary so this so like this
uh this triple is in that you know Delta
of this G if I pick a different triple
it might not be in Delta of this G but
there is going to be an edge color
between each vertex so there's a
different there's a different Triad
obtained by taking different colors that
will contain the triple
does that make sense
yeah so right so the point is that if
you look at if you look at like any any
any triple right any triple from here
you can find some G who so that it's a
triangle from that Triad and the way you
do it is you just pick this color that
this color this color in that color okay
and by doing that you can see that
looking at like Delta of G as G ranges
over all the Triads you get a partition
of the set of triples that are in
different vertex parts
so that's sort of I think that's like
the the most important picture to have
in mind so
so you've got you've got these Triads
but the
the important thing to know is just that
you know each triple is associated to a
Triad the one where the edge colors come
from The Edge colors used to make the
triangle
foreign
so right so a Triad is going to be our
Niche is going to a regular Triad is
going to replace regular hair
now
uh this is what it's gonna okay so this
is where I kind of explain what it means
to be a regular Triad so so far I
haven't mentioned the hypergraph this
was just like a notion of partitioning
vertices and pairs of vertices of a
Vertex set and now we're going to
introduce a hypergraph on the same
vertex set and talk about what it means
for the decomposition to be regular with
respect to the hypergraph so the
hypergraph consists of triples of
vertices and the the P is partitioning
the the The Singletons in pairs
so I'll say that I'll say that P is
Epsilon so there's two parameters to
this I'll say it's Epsilon one Epsilon
to regular with respect to the
hypergraph if Epsilon 1 almost all of
the triples are in a Delta G satisfying
these properties which I'll go through
slowly in one second and so the idea is
that um okay almost all the triples
from here have the property that they're
in different vertex parts that's just
standard counting so almost all of the
vertices are in Delta G for some Triad G
which which Triad well
you know I pick
I pick a Vertex here and I just pick you
know whatever whatever this color is I
pick that p i j Alpha I pick this p J K
Beta And I pick that p i k gamma
almost all the triples have a Triad that
they're in that's kind of the important
part from the last slide and so this is
saying that not only are they almost all
in a Triad but something else important
happens in their Triad so what does it
mean
so first of all we say that so so almost
all of them are in like a spec like a
Triad with a special property with
respect to H what are the special
properties so first of all as a graph
the edges of G are quasi-ran like quasi
randomly distributed and that's measured
using the Epsilon 2 parameter
and on the other hand bullet 2 says that
the edges of H are uniformly distributed
relative to the triangles from G and
that by by uniformly distributed we
measure that with an Epsilon the Epsilon
one
what does it mean to be uniformly
distributed relative to the triangles
well it means like
like I said if I look at this Triad
not all the triples here are in a
triangle from the Triad but it's saying
that if I if I look at what Pro I look
at only the triples that are are in a
triangle of the Triad and then I ask
well how many of those triples are also
edges in h also ternary edges
and then I X and then I and then you
insist that that's sort of robust
bypassing to like Sub sub graphs
basically of the Triad
so so that so that's roughly what this
means I think I've attempted to give
more details about what this means and I
don't think it's uh helpful basically
it's a lot to it's like it's a lot to
digest but that's this is like the rough
idea what it means in the and there's
two parameters the Epsilon two measuring
kind of how how quasi-random the
underlying G is and then there's the
Epsilon one parameter measuring like how
how quasi randomly is H distributed on
the triangles yeah
does it mean that once you fix it it's
right G and you look on all your son
been secure and just in age without
having to described and say this doesn't
change much to be like if it's more
fraction yeah or even if you pass to a
small sub like a sub graph is that right
or maybe it's just
disease so yes I think it's even if you
just take us like a sub graph
ICS
yeah
okay so this is uh this is so now that
we know what that means this is Franklin
okay and I I guess I should have I meant
to preview to you that this Epsilon 2 is
usually in practice really really tiny
compared to the Epsilon one parameter
and so the regularity Lemma of Franklin
rodel says the following
um so basically okay so it says for any
Epsilon one and now instead of like a
fixed Epsilon two I'm gonna have a
function
and we're gonna have we're gonna have
that that Epsilon one Epsilon to
regularity where the Epsilon 2 is going
to be tiny not just compared to Epsilon
one but like compared to the the number
of edge colors
okay so it says that for any Epsilon one
and function Epsilon 2 there are these
bounds t0 l0 so that for any
sufficiently large three graph I can
find like a little T and A little l so
the t's go with like the like the number
of vertex pieces and the L goes with the
number of edge colors I can find uh a
decomposition P whose T is bounded by
this thing and whose L is bounded by
that thing so that it's Epsilon 1
Epsilon two of L regular
so you know Epsilon two of L might be
like one over L to the 100 or something
important that it's allowed to become
small relative to the number of edge
colors
all right so this is right so this is a
statement by Franklin rodel
um
yes so so anyways so so this is the this
is the particular like
statement of the regularity level will
focus on here
all right so uh the proof gives a wowser
type Bound for both the T naught and the
L naught
um right and why Wowzer I mean like you
compose the Tower with itself
exercise
all right so a theorem of moshkovitz and
Shapiro showed that the wowser bounds
are necessary for the Tina
in general so this means like
you know so again like just like with
the normal regularity Lemma the
applications again are like what what
you can use this for is always going to
be sort of limited by like the form
those bounds take so you kind of want to
understand what's the form of the bounce
the proof yields a wowser so this
theorem shows that you can't avoid the
wowser for the T
all right so uh the okay so and you may
be wondering what's going on with the l
so we're going to return to that
so
um right so the theorem about to state
is like a
an analog of okay we're gonna get like
some kind of nice bound under a
certainness assumption
all right but we don't want to work with
like
normal VC Dimension we're going to work
with kind of a higher order version
um that happen to have been defined by
shella uh
or something
so anyway I'll tell you what it means in
the three uniform case so we'll say a
hypergraph has a three uniform
hypergraph has VC two Dimension at least
l
if there are A1 through a l and B1
through BL so that for every subset of
now the Cartesian product L cross l
you can find a Vertex C who connects to
only those elements in the subset of the
Cartesian product
so instead of like for normal VC to
mention your shattering sets of
Singletons now you're well you're still
here shattering a set of Singletons but
the set takes the form of a Cartesian
product of sets so you have
I have like A1 a l
b one b l and for any subset any subset
of the I mean this isn't a good picture
let's draw it as like a square
so it's like
I have B1 through BL A1 through a l and
now for any subset of the Cartesian
product I have somebody who connects to
exactly that set and nobody else
so it's it's yeah so you're shattering
kind of two-dimensional sex instead of
one dimensional
okay so uh
all right and so I guess uh maybe this
slide is at the end but already Julia
and I had shown that
um just as a as a corollary of the
counting Lemma if the hypergraph has
bounded vc2 Dimension you can obtain a
regular decompositions where the Triads
have density like near zero or irregular
Triads
um so what I'm talking about today is is
some is like a on top of that I prove
that you can improve one of the bounds
the the T part of this theorem is for
the L zero
okay so this says for any Epsilon one
Epsilon two parameters uh in your
theorem you can and any okay like the
lower back for any K you can find an
upper bound L and now the okay the
statement of the theorem is like exactly
the same as the Franklin rodal except
I'm assuming the vc2 dimension isn't
most k
but and I have this new addition that
the I can take the upper Bound for the
number of edge colors to be polynomial
and Epsilon one
now I think this should not be okay now
this is the duel again or something
I think I put K and I meant to come back
and check what that should be
sorry apologies
um
right so
um yes so you can you can indeed under
this assumption um obtain a polynomial
Bound in the L
I wish I was surprised by I thought this
was a very strange
so uh I want to just say a couple words
about the proof
um so the way it works is like I said we
had Julia and I had already shown that
if you have the bounded vc2 Dimension
you can get a regularity Lemma where on
all the on almost all the Triads The
Edge density is close to zero or close
to one
and now you can move to a you there you
can then move to a quotient structure
which it's it's a quote it's a graph
that's built out of the regular
decomposition
um and but it doesn't quite have bounded
VC Dimension but it has sort of locally
bounded BC dimension so the the idea is
sort of that you build the quotient
um and you build the quotient so that
like one set of vertices are sort of
going like this and the other parts are
like the edge colors this part's not
going to make sense but just to give you
a really vague idea and then
what happens is is that you get kind of
a reduced graph so that
when you localize to a single pair the
reduced graph you have has bounded BC
dimension
so so it's it's only locally bounded
it's like yeah so so there's there's a
sense in which there's like if you zoom
in on a single pair you have a quotient
a quotient graph that you've built out
of the regular decomposition that has
bounded BC dimension
yeah is there some dichotomy here
no
no actually there's some there's some
open questions I'd love for people at
cleanup for me so
um
do you have this local bound on the BC
dimension and then on each on each of
these local these so do you have like a
whole bunch a whole mess of grass that
have found a VC Dimension and then you
apply the house they're packing Lemma
and this method here is essentially the
method used in the fox pox suit paper
um and you get kind of a nice partition
with respect to these bounded VC
Dimension graphs and then you show that
you can kind of amalgamate these
partitions in such a way that you get a
partition for the whole
so that's a really vague outline okay so
now I'll say so I'll say sort of some
open questions and I don't know if I'll
get to all the slides but
um
because of okay so when we when Julia
and I proved this theorem the way you do
it is you just apply the Frankl rotol
regularity Lemma and then you use the
counting limit to show that if the vc2
dimensions bounded the Triads have to
have density near zero
okay so in particular this proof starts
with that theorem and so thus I do
nothing to the t0 and and so the t0
stays the same it's the same t0 as in
the Franco Road author yeah
[Music]
if I thought about it
um okay so of course okay one question
that that comes up immediately is under
the assumption found in bc2 dimension
can the T be improved can you get it
like sub wowser and I've gone back and
forth a lot on this I have I have
colleagues with opinions
um I still think the answer is no right
now
um
yeah well the one I showed you from the
Fox Fox suit paper for example you can
that that regular partition is stronger
than this one
so under that assumption you get
polynomials
um
okay uh
yes only right okay and now we come to
the most important um open question
which is
um like I said the the shapironments
paper doesn't explicitly say anything
about the email around
so so it's possible that that they and
that that you know they understand that
that this also needs to be a wowser but
but I don't so I would love for somebody
to show that the L zero needs to be
Wowzer like to give an example showing
the l0 has to be a Wowzer in general
because right now my theorem I guess is
not saying anything until someone does
I think I think it's I think I think
this should be true this should
certainly be true I think
um
I I have a I have a model Theory friend
who who says that that he thinks this is
obvious after spending time but there's
nothing but there's nothing written down
explicitly so
that would be nice
um okay and now
I was gonna I'm gonna give a little
preview to Julia's talk I think
um really quickly so now now I guess you
can that's the that's the end of like
the the main talk so I'm gonna now this
is I guess like story time or something
so
um there's another way in which okay so
right the general theme is sort of uh
about you have a hereditary property
what kind of structural dichotomies can
you detect using kind of
the regularity Lemma as a measure of
complexity so we've kind of talked about
bounds
um and you can also ask about irregular
pairs so given a graph I'll say it has
the K order property if there are A1
through AK B1 through BK so that a i and
EJ are an edge if and only if I is less
than or equal to J so you're just
encoding kind of a bipartite order
or this is often called a half graph if
you draw The adjacency Matrix you color
in like
so we and now this is terminology coming
from model Theory I'll say that g is K
stable if it does not have the K order
property
this is the notion of tameness coming
from model Theory
and I'll stay a hereditary graph
property is stable if there's some K so
that everything in the property is case
stable so you can think of this as like
another notion of complexity Associated
to a hereditary graph property being
stable is stronger than having bounded
BC dimension
this is like a subclass of the the
bounded VC Dimension case
so I'll say that the prop a property is
irregular free if basically you always
have regular partitions with no
irregular pairs
I don't know someone can maybe help me I
don't know this isn't a great I made
this up this morning I don't have a
better word for this
um okay so the natural question is okay
is every graph property regular free do
you can you just get rid of them all the
time so that was like the first question
and
um
and now this is folklore it's not in the
literature but I've seen it attributed
to lovas Seymour Trotter and Allen left
Monroe you sir
um which is that if you're not stable
then you're not irregular free
so if you have a large if you have
arbitrarily large half graphs you have
to have a regular pairs
and on the other hand
um much later maliaris and shelloff
using ideas for model Theory prove that
if H is stable so if you have a uniform
bound on the height of a half graph then
you're irregular free you have regular
partitions with no regular list
so again you get a dichotomy
which says that you're irregular free if
and only if you're stable and the in
what sense is this a dichotomy well
there's also
um you know once you once you have a
half graph it's not like you just have
one irregular pair you kind of have a
lot
so there is sort of a dichotomy there
um
right so the preview is I guess this is
like a little account of some other
things that have been done around tame
hypergraph regularity lemmas
um so I first I guess I'll very quickly
mention that chernokov and tausner have
related results for the VC the vck
dimension okay their methods are
infinitiary so so it's it's
it's not exactly clear if you can like
deduce one from the other vice versa and
so they don't have explicit bounds uh
they obviously they don't have this
polynomial bound or any bound any
explicit bound so they use like Ultra
products
um okay so with Julia
um
we like I said prove that this is a
paper where we proved that just sort of
um the First vc2 Dimension uh
composition
uh but I also wanted ah yeah so here's
here's the advertisement so we also show
that higher there's a notion of higher
arity stability that characterizes
special behavior of The Irregular Triads
so we proved like a hypergraph analog of
the maliara Sherlock result in the
setting of this more complicated
hypergraphic query
um and that work was largely inspired by
or motivated by and now like companion
work in the arithmetic setting around a
tameness condition that gives you like
really
um control over the error in quadratic
decompositions so I think that's what
Julia's talking about tomorrow
so
[Music]
um
right and I think okay now that's the
end of the talk so
[Applause]
I mean so this is a special case
no another special case it's so exciting
a bit small if you try to see if there's
any a little bit of hypergraphs it will
make sense
[Music]
Samsung is a different special test
yeah I'm trying to remember but there's
this paper about the dual sign rank in
BC Edition
um
sorry
I think it's just silence
is it um
but that's yeah that's different than
just cycling oh okay so maybe I don't
know maybe I don't know maybe I don't
remember what sign language is yeah yeah
so I guess
starts with University they looked into
that theory they're going to do that
nice geometric structure but I don't
know what it means for hypographs
yeah yeah I know that's really
interesting I don't know
there's a related question which I tried
to solve with a grad student and failed
which is an analog of that um connection
to this between the sign Rank and the DC
Dimension with so you take the higher
order vc2 Dimension what notion of rank
result
you couldn't quite figure out what the
right right was because there's a lot of
uh candidates so yeah that's an
interesting question for that reason
I guess
like there are these regularities stuff
for semi-algebraic properties
are they also true for hypographs
because yeah yeah so those so those are
known for example for semi-algebraic
hypergraphs those are not yeah so found
the sound rank means
yes oh so in that case I guess it would
be none but it looks like the fox Park
superzole but the right where instead of
Destiny here zero one you get like
that's exactly zero one I think
I'm not prepared to give you like the
correct attributions to those students
obviously there's also I guess
later but there's also this um stability
for graphs is equivalent to this notion
of little Stone Dimension yeah and I
wonder if the analog is to provide for
your apps
I I have no idea I mean I think the
place to start with that would be to
look at the vc2 dimension because the
understanding about VC Dimension and
like pack learning is like an older
connection and so I would think that
first this would be easier to understand
complexity notion associated
anyone else I have a question
um uh hypergraph regularity and um
uh has all these nice applications and
added Parts like all these dimensional
somebody's theorem and other things
um and the discrete geometry and some
other areas uh and our the work with uh
with talking soup we were motivated by
the Irish final conjecture and some
variations of that
um just wondering if you have some
applications in mind for these new
things if they're there are variants of
the irrational conjecture for example
for hypercrafts
but I I was wondering if you had any
applications that you were thinking of
at least
I think they're just very beautiful by
themselves like you have it's just you
have you have all of her to take off
properties and they fall into two
classes with like these wildly different
structural properties so to me that was
that's like my main motivation that I
think
uh so I haven't thought a lot about
about yeah
they're all like different versions of
other channel
um
you can do this
any other questions
I have a question generally about the
regularity levels is that is there an
ocean for weighted crops like uh
probated hypergraphs let's say
some of the mixes let's say one or
something and then you want to preserve
it
I mean you could just take
so the Frankel riddle paper contains a
statement for like
severalish colors so
I don't know
yeah I feel like you could likely reduce
this from the literature yeah
I think I think if you look around
sorry sorry one more question you said
you were motivated by this dichotomy
there's another dichotomy for Ben and BC
Dimension that if you look at the
um I can't remember what's called the
speed of the hereditary family yes
um thank you for asking okay because I
several years ago proved that a similar
dichotomy holds a DC Kate Edition
then the speed is like this for someone
to see
and uh if it has bounded VC pay
Dimension it's like this
organ Epsilon depends on the dimension
yes yes thank you so much for asking so
the first one is greater than or equal
to the next one's what three yeah
I've spent a lot of time on these these
counting problems
yeah okay I mean actually
I mean yeah I don't know uh no I mean
obviously there are properties like yes
that you can't do better than this like
there are properties that like actually
oscillate between
they kind of oscillate infinitely often
between these two ranges so in in
general you're not gonna like improve
this sound
or find any more kind of jokes in here
but this is a yeah this is like the best
other question I think for looking for
these psychologies